the 737 max has been grounded for almost
a year after two crashes killed almost
350 people now staff communications
revealed Boeing employees were concerned
about safety before the accidents and
the company was determined to oppose
regulators in March 2017 Boeing's chief
technical pilot wrote I want to stress
the importance of holding firm that
there will not be any type of simulator
training required to transition from ng
to max
Boeing will not allow that to happen
we'll go face to face with any regulator
who tries to make that a requirement a
month later another employee wrote this
airplane is designed by clowns who in
turn are supervised by monkeys and in
February 2018 a staff member asked a
colleague would you put your family on a
max simulator trained aircraft
I wouldn't the answer no just nine
months later a lion air 737 max crashed
in Indonesia followed four months later
by an Ethiopian Airlines model both
accidents caused by a software failure
that left pilots powerless they're
outraged by the repla sness and by the
lack of regard for safety that these
messages reveal that the concern about
getting the plane into the air into the
marketplace so that they could compete
with the likes of Airbus they're putting
profits over safety complete lack of
respect or responsibility towards the
regulator what the regulator's therefore
we showed the documents to a former
pilot and chief inspector for the Civil
Aviation Authority
he said the messages display contempt
for US regulators they just weren't in
the picture they were regarded as a bit
of a nuisance perhaps but nothing more
and they were there was almost an
atmosphere of autonomous you know we're
the king here throughout last year
Boeing insisted it would have the 737
max back in the air flying passengers in
and out of Heathrow and airports around
the world by now but the fleet remains
grounded the product
and line stopped and there are serious
questions as to whether this aircraft
will ever fly again with 5,000 models
already ordered Boeing and its customers
need and expect the 737 max to return to
service but if the people who built and
tested the plane don't trust it
passengers may ask why should they
Paul Kelso Sky News a Heathrow